you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
15-2 game that's a little bit different
isn't it be four against oops um so
let's see what we get certainly going
down a different route here my opponent
is baffled baffled by b4
all right so kind of going into muddy
waters already okay this is the idea so
let's do it
you take B I take E it's not just I mean
there's more going on here besides just
an exchange of ponds we consider we can
consider the weight of each pond who's
more valuable really the center pond or
the B pond but it doesn't stop there we
can look at the time element as well and
white will be losing some time as the
bishop on e5 can be struck out with
these this developing move with tempo so
this was actually a perfectly fine move
meeting Bishop takes pawn with Knight f6
and then soon knight c6 developing with
tempo so um to be honest I kind of a I
kind of like my position now I like that
I have some Queen side space and that I
don't have to tend to this pawn they
just block the bishops view of b4 so I
have some space here and I imagine that
there's this Knight is experiencing some
anxiety
see six is no longer a reliable home I
can always give him a boot
so I'm really just looking into one day
cracking at E 5 and I think a good start
is with III preparing d 4 I can also
consider C 4 and I'll probably end up
going with forming this type of pandu oh
maybe right now C for one thing I want
to be cautious of is too early a
deployment of my king night because you
know similar to equip their Queen night
coming to c6 my knight on f3 can be
kicked in a blink so I'm spending some
time here the usual case but I want to
figure out how exactly I should be
deploying my minor pieces and completing
development I have many different
candidate was running through my mind C
for D for any other ones probably I
should probably start with C for yeah I
think I know where my C pawn belongs so
once actually do this first and you know
another idea behind committing first my
C pawn when compared to the deep on
maybe I don't want to go to squares with
my D pawn I see him as the more flexible
of the two so I'm going to go with the
least flexible pawn first that said
eventually I will have to make a
commitment with pipe on after all that I
still may just end up playing d5 after
all said and done and you know what we
are um with that move throwing a strike
here
hmm to play d5 96 I don't know if I
really want to play knight c6 I think I
first want to see how black reacts if I
put pressure on it with d4 and another
thing if my knight placed at f3 and
eventually this move comes like for
example d4 Knight d7 and I play Knight
f3 if then II four I have this
convenient I think at least Knight D to
move which immediately apply some
pressure to this pawn that's in my
position
a check here but that does nothing
my concern here is that on d4 black I'll
just take and should that really be so
much of a concern I mean how would I be
recapturing mm-hmm not quite sure to be
honest go with the Queen this kind of
concerns me if I'm taking with the
bishop or the Queen there's knight c6
suppose I just play Knight f3 for
starters because ideally if I could play
Knight f3 suppose on Knight f3 castles
and then I play d4 if takes I could just
take with the night and he's fearless a
knight c6 move isn't going to make my
knight I'm not going to be afraid of
night some nights e6 move challenging my
knight on d4 so if I could work out
Knight f3 and E 4 and be satisfied that
this maybe isn't such a good idea I
should probably go with this so Knight
f3 e4 I think I think black would be a
bit overextended if they do that hmm
I could baby step it as well just go d3
Knight f3 Bishop e2 connect Knights
Queen c2 I could play a little bit slow
and you know what I'm actually going to
lean a bit towards that first just d3
this isn't to say that at one point I
won't play d4 but I think I want to go
with a little bit more of a build up and
not be kicked around with an e4 move
because this is an important point
because we could enter a different
structure like Knight f3 e4 Knight d4
maybe black is able to maintain upon on
e4 going with this
c6 d5 thing
um a bit torn
well let's make a decision I'm gonna I'm
gonna baby step it just go at d3 okay 9
minutes 2 seconds 5 minutes in alright
but I think I know where I want the rest
of my pieces I certainly know where my
kingside pieces belong I think he's
going to lag some I'm not sure which is
best let's get my night out Bishop e2
everybody knows that that's where he
belongs
so I have pressure on e5 so getting this
in would require much more support a
knight of rook before this is even a
thought I mean black still could do this
you know I take here Bishop takes there
just like we had very early on but yeah
if black is going to get in some pawn
break or if they're going to get some
central expansion in like this that this
guy needs a lot more support
so I like the space that I have should a
five occur I think I'll not budge with
my beep on I think I like keeping
control over c5 we don't want to allow
something like this it's a very flexible
pawn setup
nothing yet fixed it's not a static
structure Bishop e2 and castles I think
I'll be looking forward to those two
moves before declaring my queen Knight
as far as my queen
these seem like - pretty good options
I'll hold off on that because a lot more
will happen before that even comes about
we'll see what black does if they're
ever moving their F pawn my Queen's eyes
might light up a bit more about being
opposite the King so this is almost a
guaranteed just develop break a pin and
get him back to full strength
it's a simple enough move with this
Bishop on g4 he's not so much of an
inconvenience I see this as well I don't
know kind of plays into my hands in a
way like I like that I'll one day be
able to insert h3 and have a useful
flight square for my King and I get to
do so with tempo but okay first things
first they just developed and are no
striking at b4 so I could immediately
give him a boot but do I want to do that
is this an annoying square I think I'm
alright with just playing a three I like
keeping this pawn duo sitting just a
three don't believe I'm missing anything
if they play a five then I can maybe
consider this
if I play b5 right now where is it going
to go you see I like here's here's what
I'm thinking here I'm thinking if I play
b5 I'm kind of a bit overextended on b5
Knight a5 I'm pretty sure soon there's
going to be some strike mi b5 pun so
it's a modest looking move but I
wouldn't go with just a3 let me let me
also just know how many moves I'm away
before connecting my rocks 1 2 3 lack is
only one move away but I don't think I
should be in any serious danger by being
a little bit behind development wise
yeah I mean what would be the great
danger the position opening up very
quickly but I think I'm going to find
position to cope with that let's go with
a three castles I may know where my
Queen belongs before my knight who knows
I'm pretty much looking at castles in
some cases it may in some structures you
could see and a much earlier commitment
of the Queen Knight - d - connecting
Knights so that you're in a position to
a challenge the bishop and should there
be a bishop for a knight exchange the
knight would be the more useful piece to
recapture on f3 I don't see that being
the case in this position as it's still
a fluid structure undefined structure
and investing the bishop for Knight
exchange would not be a wise choice I
don't believe main reason behind that is
because you know
the Knights where are their homes
exactly there aren't any holes really
that you could take advantage of in this
position
all right let's castle so yeah
Bishop's important pieces may be a
reason to shy away from an early Queen
move well if I'm going Queen here Knight
here my bishops unprotected you know
earlier I said when I played my bishop
here developing and breaking the pin my
knight is back on full strength well if
I do Queen c2 Knight here
he's unprotected and I know I could look
for a light square bishop exchange one
day the night on d2 seems pretty
flexible and I mean another thing on c3
he's up one more rank but at the same
time he's placing a blindfold over my
bishop so I think I'm leaning more
towards d2 with my queen Knight as far
as candidate moves in the black end
they're still seeking a pawn break well
so am i but I think I'm fine I benefit
in fact by whatever pawn break black
throws at me so from a development
standpoint I don't think the difference
here me being two moves back before
there's the connection and white only
being army being two black only being
one move away from having that
connection I don't think that that's so
much a factor here I think it's a lot
has to do a lot is related to the space
that I have I feel like I have some
advantage here space on the Queen side
where did the
belong I don't know hopefully a couple
moves from now they'll be a bit more
clarity and you know some some pollen
advance will take place in a file will
have would be for half-opened and then
I'll certainly feel a bit more confident
about where exactly the rooks belong if
I had to anticipate where my rooks would
be long right now without their already
being some pawn break on board somehow a
half open file on board or open file I'm
leaning towards the C and D files you
know because this move could play hand
boom we have the D file open up where
this move could be played and then we
have the C file opening up
this move makes me shy away from h3 and
also makes me think back as to my last
decision here to Castle I wonder if I
should have first inserted h3 that way
I'm at the very least not having to
calculate does this sacrifice work maybe
this was better earlier I think what
blacks plan could be is a playing here
and then d5 but no I think I'll be all
right
if that happens um yeah I think I'm
going to connect Knights
it might be a good idea to make a
recapture with a knight here this is
maybe starting to show up in this
position because should the D file open
up this is a potential target and so
I'll want to keep my Bishop around to
defend III take stakes I'm losing some
defense of over d3 and I believe when d5
does hit and I think it will well they
actually know there's still some more
prep work as mentioned a little bit
earlier 'if I've is lacking some defense
as soon as this move is played so I
guess they're a couple moves away black
would be all right just one move first
Bishop here and then d5 and I guess
they're one move away before this is
maybe even an idea also they probably
have some concern over there Knight you
know what's one of the things that's
probably running through their mind is
well should be 5 be played where's my
knight going to go exactly yeah I might
have I'm sure I don't know I just I'm a
little bit upset with myself with not
anticipating this and I want to be able
to get in that h3 move it's not it's not
something that'll really show up on the
evaluation but um somehow I feel that
that was most accurate to kind of
squeeze the most out of the this bishops
position hit him before this is even you
know something I need to calculate I
don't think it would be something I'd
have to fear h3 if takes takes what
could I do
I could play Knight to h2 and then
Bishop g4 Queen of 3 they'd only be
having well it's only really the Queen
that could cause any problems this pawn
and well you could even chalk it up as
the bishop does a very good job at
negating any night drifting towards my
king
should there be a queen on the h3 square
my bishop does a good job in restricting
this guy and how does black enter with
one other piece should h3 and a
sacrifice occur in h3 I'm not quite
seeing it I can always go about things
like rook e1 Bishop f1 and then there's
absolutely no fear of a sacrifice on h3
should my bishop reside on f1 so after a
lot of time on my end early on my
opponent has also gone into the think
tank 5 minutes 15 they have now a flight
square
okay well I think it's okay to play
Queen c2 I know for the moment he's
unprotected I don't think that the kid I
could really take advantage of this or
you know what maybe I should go with hmm
I'm not certain that this is going to be
a useful file maybe I should play h3
let's let's just double check here h3
chop chop queen here am I going to be re
alright with that Knight h2 is my idea
yeah I think I will be okay let's see if
they go for that I don't think it's so I
don't think it's something that's
working the Queen alone is not a piece
that is really scaring me and a night on
the h2 square should act as a a
fantastic defender against the Queen and
the many checks that she would normally
have okay now that I know the bishop is
here um maybe not such a fan of playing
Queen c2 at the same time I could even
consider the move efore which is really
changing the structure hmm the same time
I we
F for and D for D for as a whole
F for is very soft and I do not have my
bishop around to defend this I could
also consider Queen C to with the idea
of Knight e4 now I know I was
calculating the sacrifice immediately
but also I should probably anticipate a
few moves down the line would this still
be working in this position I don't
believe so I don't think things have
changed enough I think my queen is
misplaced on c2 over d1 let's see that
sacrifice working here so I could look
into this these this would be a case
where doubled pawns are actually quite
good they do a good job in restricting
the d5 pawn break which is still not on
because of my pressure here this Bishop
needs to back up I thought black would
have done this maybe even before playing
h6
let's see we're about at the 4-minute
area only a dozen moves in I got that
increment I'm leaning towards a rook
move and I think I'm looking at a F rook
move to the D file so that just in case
if I do need support over here I could
drop this guy back
and should the d-file open up my rook is
there to reinforce this guy I think this
is certainly the better file the D file
for my King rook when compared to the
e-file okay now this might be a move at
the same time I think this is a moment
where I should jump in here now that the
bishop isn't defending the knight when I
play 94 I'm striking here and
threatening to damage the King sight
structure so 94 9 takes pawn takes I
think is a favorable structural change
I'm going to go for that let's drop him
in there and if I end up with these
double D pawns I could be certain okay I
can be certain that this is a fantastic
file for my rooks now what black might
be lining up is an f5 break next this is
ruled out I don't see any beneficial
Queen side pawn breaks for black the
only one I'm now seeing is this a bishop
backing up to one of these two within f5
so maybe I can look to restrict that
pawn break but how Knight here is maybe
an idea yeah I was pointing at these two
if you really want to be sure that the
this move gets in if that's really the
idea oh really oh did I miss this now
no man
we got this coming I got a calculate and
stuff okay let's put on the thinking cap
on takes Queen takes Knight H two rookie
six King H one on there in time to
contest the rook and the rook isn't
making use of H six don't think that
this is working well I'm pretty sure I
have to take so let's do that first
just double check pawn takes Queen takes
Knight H two rookie six King H one rook
g6 threatens mate rook g1 and it may be
me who's soon on the attack don't think
that this is working Knight H two super
defender he's not contributing nor is he
King H 1 and rook 2 G 1 you know I think
this is just not working
everything else is uh I have everything
defended in fact oh no I was going to
say I had this move but the rook can
just come over and break or pin my
bishop to the King so this is a threat
there pretty much has to come here rook
g1 the only thing that's going to stop
me from maybe playing Rick g1 is Queen
h4 putting pressure on f2 but my queen
could always defend there I could play
first Bishop g4 if Queen h4 Bishop g4
striking at the rook and then rook g1
next
the rocket plate f6 my knight is pinned
but a super defender or even rook f6
would stop my rook from getting to g1
black has to do something that stops
rook g1 now this is a welcome sight I
want to play here anyway and I just get
to parry the threat just double-checking
I want to fall for a male 1 there is one
other move Bishop f3 to consider I guess
but hey this is a this is where you want
to be right defend mate go opposite
their king
let's do it
my rooks are connected I'm ready to
contest files
I'd like to see captures because he gets
to develop it's not doing anything on
the a file
what should block do I think Shaitan
they should just leave this sitting and
somehow try to get another piece
involved maybe of night here so that if
I capture this night is now starting to
drift in this area
but
to capture what would I do on 97 is what
I should be figuring out right now I
could play Bishop g4 Bishop g4 there's
only one move Queen h4 okay so now
they're playing there but this gives me
time to just play rook g2 or even rook
g3 this Queen also feels pretty short on
squares no here here is almost wrapping
the Queen if Knight f3 was not illegal
yeah you still pinned so rook g2 rook g3
umm-hmm I just look here huh yeah let's
see yeah let's do this
let's not chew up all my time here and
live off of the increment let's have a
little bit of a cushion huh there at the
25 okay so they're bringing another
piece involved probably just get this
guy running huh yeah let's do it
rook here well they're running right
into this I'm winning a full rook now am
i helping out any of the other black
pieces by making this capture don't see
it they're minor pieces are non-existent
in this attack that is it's a specific
major piece attack this is also
desirable because my queen now gets to
help out in the defense of f2 let's do
it I'm soon to be up a rook for just a
couple pounds can also even look into f4
although you know III could look into f4
maybe they would
sign em
they might resign right then and they
did you know they're soon to be down a
rook for not enough compensation clearly
there's just not going to be an attack
here always a little bit of a scary
sacrifice to cope with I I thought it
wasn't working but it's I don't know
when it's on board it's still a little
bit I don't know the feeling I get is a
little the nerves kick in a little bit
you know thinking that you may be
overlooked something but okay let's uh
dive into the analysis and see as
mentioned after Bishop b2 black should I
think just go straight in for this and
I'm hitting here just develop one move I
play something like III and then there's
knight c6 with tempo Bishop backs up and
d5 Black has a rapid development notice
there one two three moves away whereas
still have a lot of work to do one two
three four five six in the long term I
mean if I could mmm get some more
development in you know I do have this
as a long-term Trump the central
majority two to one which may be
converted into a two to zero majority
the C pawn is exchanged for the D pawn
that's like that's what can result so
this is another approach I mean you
don't look at it as just oh the center
pawn is more valuable than a beep on so
I'm not going to go in for that exchange
there is also that time element where
I'm decide who's really going going to
be wasting time if we consider the both
Bishop positions I can't make a good
developing move I don't think at least
where I'm striking at the bishop
on b4 whereas it's quite clear black can
with knight c6 I have the more
vulnerable patient and Bishop even
though I picked up a center pawn and
gave up a knight pawn ok well that
didn't happen in the game d6 instead and
you know this is I kind of squeezed the
as much as I could out of my beep on
here you know it's a multi-purpose move
and there's really no downside now
connected with b4 as far as I could tell
that's preparing the fee in keto and
also it has this space element with it
could be disruptive to the night as was
played in the game he ended up just
sitting on b4 and I think I'm I think
I'm fine I'll have a quick look with the
computer about playing d3 at this point
I spent a lot of time in the open and
trying to figure out how exactly to
organize and I think it's I think it's
right I think it's fine playing it like
this just a little bit of a
non-confrontational setup just being
prepared for the different pawn breaks
securing the knight position so he
doesn't get kicked if I'm doing this
right away I guess e4 there's even c5 I
think and I don't like that this is a a
whole and be a square that black already
has pawn support for its kind of rubs me
the wrong way I probably could still do
this you know and then look to undermine
the pawn and I'm not saying c5 would be
the follow-up move after E for knight
deform but this was this was kind of my
concern here and then if this this
this pond lives is it a liability or
NASA I'm not quite sure maybe maybe this
is actually a bit scary because you know
what now this advance here right here
when when this move comes in notice now
the b4 pawn is struck out again and I
don't have I'm not I'm not hitting out
there a 5-pound anymore he's clearly
advanced so maybe this could turn out to
be a turn out to be something black and
take advantage of in some variations
this one here maybe
as played I wanted to make sure when my
tonight was going to f3 he would stay
there a little bit upset with myself
with the castles I think if I could do
it over again I first play h3 he's going
here I certainly don't have to worry
about any sacrifices but okay it's maybe
being a bit too technical about eggs
I don't know trying to play the the
absolute best moves or what I think are
at least I'm trying to play the the best
moves so Bishop FA 94 I think is a good
idea and I just don't think that this
I'm pretty sure that this isn't working
well have it we'll double-check it
the other line is I think here and then
trying for f5 and I really didn't get to
voice how exactly I would go about
combating f5 I don't think black is well
prepared to get this advance in you
really like to have the rook on f8 with
that um this Knight is under control the
bishop isn't contributing the rook I
don't really see doing much they have
one idea in mind if I stopped that I
think I'm really in the driver's seat
um Knight h4 and Bishop d3 and I was
leaning more towards Bishop d3 to combat
f5 I really don't want to allow this
pawn to move
black could maybe move with him but
they'd have to invest some material you
know this isn't winning anything for him
could just take and well I mean this
Bishop size has just opened up if black
ever wants to get something like that in
so this is what I was planning on doing
Bishop d3 but I didn't like about Knight
h4 is that he's a unprotected and well
actually that's pretty much the main
reason if it's a different story if I
could be assured I'd get to this square
but they maybe even have a prep move
like g6 and then I don't know it rubs me
the wrong way that this Knight is on the
edge and unprotected vulnerable to the
Queen or Bishop so I probably would have
played Bishop d3 and well suppose they
insisted on it with g6 hmm well if
they're going to go with f5 they are
they are really weakening their King
position so if things are going to be
opening up I think I'd like to have this
diagonal open maybe something like c5
right around here is an idea or maybe
even Knight d2 preparing to meet f5 with
f4 and things are much more tense not
quite sure how to evaluate this position
but what I do know is that my king is
the more safer of the - I have a g2 h3
shelter and g6 h6 you know I have a fine
pocket for my King
sheltering against rank checks black
hint black doesn't have that
not sure if I would have played this
exactly but yeah this is this is what
would certainly have my attention is the
one pawn break for a black f5 and I'd
look to control that because if I could
control that I believe I control the
game we'll see what's computer says I'm
sure that that's just not working and
yeah they just lost some more material
with that Bishop g4 move so let's put on
the engine see what it has to say here
good even though
well the others the graph you know so
slight advantage for black right out of
the gate computer is not a fan of the
move 1b for the ring orangutan okay yeah
just kind of what are they calling it
the polish is another name for it okay
just kind of skimming here when you put
on the arrows want to see about the d3
move 192 okay see for now still give it
a little bit of time here till the green
reaches all the way over its when it
does its best thinking close enough okay
see four won't be waiting on every move
for it to do that but d3 Knight c3 yeah
as mentioned I want to stay flexible
with him I didn't know really which was
the better square I don't know if I
really want to mask the bishop size if
I'm doing that maybe this advance is a
little bit easier to play as black
wouldn't need as much support over e5 my
knight is blocking the bishops view so
this might this might happen or at least
black might start to consider that type
of plan and with d3
only now Knight f3 okay it wants to go
straight in for b5 but I don't think
anything is wrong with a 3 E 4 I'm fine
if it opens up takes takes challenge the
piece in my position right away you know
I guess that's how did the pieces get
active and I'm fine with this because
when the heavy pieces get involved I
like having this this type of play
cracking with c5 they have this half
open file but how exactly do you break
it III would upon I'm really close to
engaging and creating some queenside
Target Lock doesn't have that I'd be
fine if e 4 was played so castles H 3 is
fine 92 yeah I guess uh I guess it's
fine how things are played out I SH it
backs up b5 it keeps coming out for I
just wanted to keep him sitting okay
it did pop up 94 I didn't want to do
this I don't want to create these this
weakness on d4 I'm pretty sure it did
pop up 94 I like this move doesn't want
to capture bishop of Bishop e7 instead
after takes yeah this is just not
working let's just double check how I
defended here Knight H 2 is correct the
rook entering Queen h4 wants to do
what's the suggestion after Queen h4
Bishop g4 so my Queens defending and
then I could play here and on rook here
I guess I could play off four huh
yeah opens up this rank for some defense
of my queen and hey let's also even
think about attacking I don't have to go
into and this isn't uh you know I have
to go into a complete prevent here or
anything like that
I could actually go on the offensive I
have I'm going to have the rook opposite
their king
he's and he's not strictly defending
peace you know as it was played here
rook g3 rook g1 yeah I'm defending the
main threat but at the same time I Mouse
opposite their king
so just uh I don't know this is just a
little mental note to myself it's really
what I'm doing here I don't have to you
know you could kind of just get caught
up like oh I'm defending defending
defending but hey why not think about
going on the aggressive here you know
these works are exchanged and then all
of a sudden you have a rook playing and
this rook is still sitting in the corner
so Queen h4 I could have done this and
this move I had f4 and on this move I
have probably rook g1 as well you know I
don't know short story here is that the
sacrifice that h3 just wasn't working
it's really just the Queen who's
attacking and I'm fast enough to defend
with my rooks as soon as one of their
Brooks tries to enter and then yeah this
is just busted so the last thing I
really want to look at is this moment
here I want to have a little bit more
clarity on this f5 break I want to see
if I can learn something more because
I'm still you know I'm not absolutely
sure of any one position but I want I
want to learn just a little bit more in
this position here where I said I was
considering Bishop d3 it seems to be
okay but as I was putting some more
moves on the board I put on g6 and then
did something like this
I guess I could play rook to d1 but let
me just do this and see what's wrong
with it
so what I like to do just play around
with the different ideas here I just
threw out and I'm not sure it's correct
but okay it's it's alright
Oh a tactical flaw
I could meet Fi with f4 and just be
welcome to this position blowing up
knowing that I have the more secure King
and I'm not going into any specific
calculation this is just that general
type of reasoning hey you want diagonals
and files open up let's you know bring
it on because I have the safer King I
have that nice shelter and you don't in
don't really have to take it too much
warm or too much deeper than that so
that is an approach I guess I could do
many different things here it's
suggesting rook d1 and now I also want
to learn what would we be doing on f5
just leave it sit you know this is
another important point it's approaching
+2 by the way looking at c5 and why not
opens up the diagonal cracks at this
pawn looking to get at the Queen here
and taking I guess is just benefiting
black right because this bishops scope
is then extended takes takes I mean it's
still beneficial for me but why give him
you know a new square to observe and why
give black/white why exchange my Center
pond for there Knight pawn if they're
going to capture me you know if there's
going to be capture let them capture me
something like this this is just
fantastic for me now okay so this is
what I could do not to get too elaborate
here but should black have backed up
here or here trying for an f5 pawn break
instead of the game sacrifice on h3 what
I could be doing is first Bishop d3 and
then rook to d1 and then look at the c5
move and if black isn't playing a5 they
have to then take on um
to describe they have to just sit in
wait and that's never a good strategy to
just not have some constructive plan but
just wait for your opponent to slowly
and steadily improve the quality of
their own position yeah
if f5 isn't working then you know
nothing is really working for black here
okay um anything more to cover yeah I
think I want to look at just one more
thing
instead of Bishop d3 I mean it keeps
pointing out rook d1 instead of this
unripe d1 is f5 now an issue let's just
put this on right here Bishop here b6
okay there's there's some tricks here
rook here is throwing a punch you know
we got some pin going on in the D file
anyhow these are some of the ideas right
rook opposite the Queen look to strike
at the pinned piece undermine e5 just
play on the Queen side play where you
have some space okay well I think that's
going to do it on a shorter game just 21
moves but as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video let me know
your thoughts and as usual I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now take care bye
you